tossed salads scrambled eggs no Nails
David Hyde Pierce reportedly won't be a
part of the Frasier Revival keep
watching to find out why miles crane
from Frasier is one of the most iconic
characters in the history of sitcoms
thus far in his career David Hyde Pierce
has earned a whopping 11 Emmy
nominations and four wins and every
single one of them was for playing Niles
in fact in a Reddit poll in 2020 Niles
was picked as a fun favorite Frasier
character in a landslide Conor Hennigan
writing for the website Joe gave a
unique perspective on what makes Niles
such a great character he points to
Nile's snobbery his vulnerability his
hilarious ongoing fuse with his brother
Frasier and Pierce's talent for physical
comedy writing about the season 6
episode 3 Valentines which features a
hilarious opening scene with Pierce as
the only human performer Hennigan said
few other actors could flourish in a six
minute scene completely on their own or
at least without any other human
presence and without a word of dialogue
hide PS managed to turn it into a master
class it's very hard to imagine exactly
what kind of show Frasier would have
been without Niles but apparently not
impossible after years of speculation
The Frasier fandom was finally treated
to the news that the iconic sitcom would
be returning well grammar is on track to
return as everyone's favorite cheers
character it looks like fans shouldn't
be hopeful for more Niles The Frasier
reboot has been discussed for some time
and David Hyde Pierce had been very
non-committal about whether or not he
would be willing to take part in it in
an interview the guardian in April
Pierre said it's happening but I don't
know in what form and I don't know when
so I don't know where I'll be and what
I'll be doing I'm certainly interested
to see what they'd come up with then in
October the deadline reported that the
reboot had officially been picked up by
Paramount plus with Kelsey Grammar as
the only original cast member expected
to return as a series regular in a
recent interview with people grammar
explained why PS opted not to return for
the show's Revival he's said David
basically decided he wasn't really
interested in repeating the performance
of Niles the actor also confirms that
the new series would take place in a new
city and focus on new supporting
characters he continued in a very funny
way it just took us to a new place which
is what we originally wanted to do
anyway which was a Frasier third act
it's an entirely new life for him he
uses the phrase third act to refer to
the fact that the upcoming series will
be the third to feature the character of
Frasier Crane following cheers and
Frasier details are ultimately slim on
the Frasier Revival and it remains to be
seen how the absence of David Hyde
Pierce's Niles is addressed in a June
interview with vulture PS maintained
that he loved his time on the series
calling it valuable which is why he
doesn't feel the need to return the
actor said because it's so valuable to
me I also wouldn't do it just to do it
PSM went on to point out how Frazier a
spin-off of Cheers didn't bring back
characters from the original series for
the sake of it Pierre said before saying
that may or may not be a way to fold
Niles into the Revival series they
didn't bring along the cheers gang to
make a new show they popped in from time
to time and it was a blast since
wrapping up his time on Frasier PS has
kept himself busy with the flurry of
Thrones he returned to his Wet Hot
American Summer role for Netflix's
two-sequel series and lent his talents
to The Good Wife for a guest appearance
he was also recently seen in HBO Max's
Julia where he played the husband of
celebrity chef Julia Child PS has also
spent his post freighter years
dominating the stage starring in
curtains and the stage adaptation of
It's a Wonderful Life PS has also gone
on to direct several Productions
including Broadway's it should have been
you while it may Sting fans Not to see
Frasier and Niles chew into one another
he is his decision to sit out the sequel
seems to be coming from a place of
genuine respect for the series
foreign
[Music]